christine christelle health infirmières
libérales sur place christelle heintz
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors en métropole notamment à
marseille la fermeture des bars et des
restaurants a suscité beaucoup de colère
c'est la même chose en guadeloupe où
c'est un peu plus mais zut mesurer non
c'est la même chose là à la mesure est
pas vraiment comprises
elle est pas facilement accepté et c'est
vrai que on a déjà beaucoup souffert
lors de leurs du confinement total
et là c'est vrai que c'est pas évident
alors pour l'infirmière que vous êtes
elles sont quand même nécessaire face à
la situation sanitaire ces mesures selon
vous ou alors il aurait peut-être fallu
en prendre d'autres
je pense qu'elles sont effectivement
nécessaire elle devrait être mieux
expliquer mieux comprise parce qu'en
fait ici les rassemblements dans la
famille et c'est assez c'est vraiment
dans les moeurs locaux et les gens
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à comprendre
qu'il ne faut pas voilà qu'il est
distanciation sociale les gestes
barrière même si beaucoup les respects
en ville dans les magasins on les voit
mais dans la sphère privée ça ne suffit
pas les bars les restaurants ils ont
pris les des mesures face à la situation
sanitaire gel hydroalcoolique à la
sortie des débats ou encore le port du
masque quand on se déplace à l'intérieur
des établissements c'est bien respecter
ou pas sur l'île en grande majorité oui
c'est respecter en grande majorité sait
respecter
après il ya toujours des petits bars des
petits lolo ou non bien sûr mais c'est
vrai que les grandes les grandes
enseignes les grands restaurants etc
respecter alors concernant la situation
notamment celle des soignants qu'elle
est elle aujourd'hui on évoque des
soignants presque en burn out est ce que
vous confirmez
alors les soignant à l'hôpital je pense
qu'effectivement sont vraiment à bout de
souffle mais nous en libéral on est
aussi à bout de souffle
c'est vrai que l'on nous sollicite pour
aller travailler et renforcer l'hôpital
mais on a nos patients à domicile et
nous on fait tout notre possible
justement pour ne pas les envoyer à
l'hôpital donc pour ne pas les
contaminer pour les garder
en meilleure santé possible et on nous
demande en plus d'aller de l'hôpital au
risque de se contaminer nous mêmes et
donc après de contaminer nos patients et
c'est quelque chose qui pour nous est
extrêmement difficile on ne peut pas on
a déjà des journées de travail qui sont
extrêmement lourdes aller en plus donner
du renfort à l'hôpital c'est très
difficile et pourtant on sait l'hôpital
complètement surchargé est débordée et
travaille vraiment dans des conditions
très très difficile non il ya me mary
oui en libéral pardonnez moi je vous ai
coupé en libéral c'est aussi très utile
pour nous parce que voilà nous on est
sur le pont tous les jours de très très
tôt le matin jusque très tard le soir et
on a non seulement notre patient
accompagner mais on a toute la famille à
éduquer toute la famille a un coût de
chez en fait parce que c'est vraiment du
coaching au quotidien et voilà avec avec
je vous dis des moeurs locaux qui sont
totalement à l'opposé de ce qu'on leur
demande de faire
alors le déploiement des renforts
militaires du service de santé des
armées est prévue est ce que c'est déjà
un soulagement oui ça va être vraiment
une grande aide
ça va être vraiment une grande aide la
réserve militaire la réserve civile va
vraiment soulager beaucoup les équipes
qui vont des équipes sur place parce
qu'elles sont vraiment épuisée en termes
de moyens sur place en termes
d'équipement en termes de masse
est-ce que vous avez le stock
suffisamment nécessaire vous par exemple
alors nous en fait un libéral on a le
stock de masques de l'état s'arrête la
semaine prochaine on a plus de dotations
de l'état officiellement la semaine
prochaine
donc on a reçu déjà un message et une
quinzaine de jours je crois où nous
demandait de faire des stocks d'acheter
du matériel mais le matériel ici à a été
multiplié par ses parts et on achète nos
gants on achète mon sur blues on achète
nos tenues y accoler le cinéma vous
parler du prix du dd
du matériel qui a fortement augmenté ces
derniers mois
oui ça a été j'ai plié parfois par dix
d'un 36 impressionnant comment est ce
que vous envisagez les prochaines
semaines au vu de la situation sur place
c'est difficile parce qu en fait autant
lors de la première vague alors qu'on
avait moins de cas et moins de moins
deux morts - dont les services étaient
moins surchargé tout le monde a pris la
mesure beaucoup plus au sérieux que je
trouve maintenant où effectivement ça
fait des mois qu'on doive ça fait
plusieurs semaines en tout cas on doit
porter le masque on nous parle de
distanciation social limite j'aurais
tendance à dire c'est presque banalisés
maintenant et alors qu'il faudrait qu'on
multiplie nos mots nos précautions
maintenant parce que les cas sont
beaucoup plus importants et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que les cas se multiplient
parce que les gens ont lâché ont lâché
prise dans ce contexte vous nous en
parler un petit peu tout à l'heure mais
votre activité en plein coli elle
ressemble à quoi aujourd'hui
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup d'éducation
beaucoup de prévention en plus parce que
tous les patients sont des patients bien
évidemment âgées fragiles on a beaucoup
diabète on a beaucoup de dialyse et on à
propos donc de patients qui qui ont des
pathologies associées qui sont des
facteurs de comorbidité qu'ils sont
majeurs et on doit le patient lui même
nous on va réussir à le gérer on à
réussir a expliqué emballé réussir à lui
faire comprendre toutes les précautions
mais la famille autour par contre ils
comprennent pas ils comprennent pas le
port du masque qui vont pas porter le
masque à côté de leurs patients et de
leurs proches ils vont pas les enfants
sont là la vie ici c'est vraiment une
vie en communauté familiale très très
très serré et leur faire comprendre les
gestes barrière le lavage des mains
c'est très gentil mais quand on a de
l'eau voilà même nous à domicile
au niveau des soins d'hygiène et de
toilette quand on a de l'eau quand on
n'a pas d'eau et bien on se débrouille
avec avec les moyens du bord avec une
cuvette avec des bouteilles dans les
écoles c'est pareil les écoles ça a été
catastrophique au niveau des fermetures
de 10 coupures d'eau merci beaucoup
crient style and d'avoir partagé votre
témoignage rappelle que vous êtes
libéral en guadeloupe